well before i let you go we got to ask
the big question what do you think is uh
is price action looking like over the
next week or so and then what is uh
what's kind of your price
thoughts through the rest of this year
we're currently sitting around 45 46 47
000 where are we going
yeah i think over the next week
um
it kind of depends like what derivatives
look like and and so you kind of have to
like look at it as as it comes like if
funding just moves all of a sudden like
open interest moons then you know we
probably get a correction there in in
the short term um so i don't know it's
kind of hard to gauge over the next week
i would say over the next couple weeks
higher um looking to kind of retest 50k
as like a pretty important level i think
we could potentially set you know
theoretically a uh lower high there but
i think like if we get above 50k the the
um
the uh legitimacy of like a thesis of
some kind of dead cat bounce i think
really dies down after we get above that
that 50k level partially because it's
like technical support
also because just in general it's a
round number right like you know
sometimes it's as simple as just looking
at like psychological levels in the
market and uh you know round numbers are
always just you know the common thing
that that price finds resistance at so
yeah i think like 50k we'll probably
retest that in the next couple weeks and
then kind of gauging the reaction there
um
and then also like
i i built like this this uh on chain
like pricing model and so it looks at um
like some of these metrics i didn't
build but i just put them all together
so it's looking at like the floor that
historically for all bitcoin um like in
the bottom of the bear market and then
also at the top um and then the mean
between the two and you're looking at
the realized price um anyway i'm
probably like boring people to death
here but there's there's one uh mid
price level that i'd be watching it's um
right around 57k right now it's kind of
like
it's sloping up or it's always adding a
couple hundred dollars a day but i think
if we get back above that um then like
it would be full confirmation in my mind
that that we're going much higher um and
then from there if we broke above 57k
like um
i'd probably be targeting the the
mean between realized price in the in
the top price so that's like right
around 92k right now and kind of
grinding slowly upwards so
okay so we'll see if we get that
confirmation but over the next couple
weeks i think we test 50. a follow-on to
that is uh i recently was talking to dan
held a couple of guys who really believe
in this like super cycle thesis where
basically they think hundreds of
thousands of dollars of bitcoin by the
end of the year do you buy any of that
um
it's hard to tell like
there's so many factors i i would say
though i think like bitcoin moves away
from this four-year cycle i i think
eventually bitcoin just becomes more
free-flowing kind of in correlation to
like real rates and and just in general
you know the raw supply and demand like
i don't think a lot of these like
overheated signals for the for the
cycles that that i look at i think
they'll all get broken at some point
whether it's like this cycle or the next
you know obviously like it's impossible
to say but
i suspect like over time bitcoin will
just become more freely traded amongst
the just ross of you know supply and
demand and trade more in in tandem with
like some of the more macro factors like
you know obviously bitcoin has been
majority uh you know retail driven so a
lot of stuff hasn't mattered but i think
you'll you'll start to move away from
like the four year cycle so yeah like
does that happen this time i know it's
hard to say i guess we'll kind of like
get a better uh grasp for that towards
the end of the year when we start to see
like
the kind of uh buyers that that announce
i think like
you'll probably have some big buyers
towards towards the the latter half of
the year just because like you know the
really strong accumulation we've been
seeing and like these people probably
aren't going to announce until it makes
them look smart to do so like why would
they announce when you know price is
still at like 40k you know they're going
to come out and announce that like
new all-time highs but oh yeah yeah we
bought that down there yeah like what do
you mean
you know they're not gonna say it now
when it doesn't make them look really
smart to do so so
i don't know long for short i think it
just depends on uh some like the more
like extraneous factors that we'll
probably get a better grasp on
throughout the year and then obviously
you know whatever's going on with it
with the dollar has a huge impact on
bitcoin right like if all of a sudden
everybody loses trust in the dollar well
then you know that's insanely bullish
for bitcoin um but you know it's really
hard to like i guess call the timing in
terms of like will that be this cycle or
next
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it